welcome to play today today three women  it's gonna cook the death Bogan Young  I'm Jean my name is Teresa AKA Freedom  my name  who make me make me comfortable to make  me smile in a man he definitely has to  make me laugh I'm really ambitious I  work really hard I made a Caribbean  birthday I think too often people follow  a recipe and they're not really paying  attention you can be 10 years and you're  like oh what is this relationship or  what is this career and yes I'm gonna be  extra and say all of that is in my dish  you can smell the onion and the mushroom  as well but I wonder what he smells like  the person who made that plate is really  meticulous because it's really well  organized well she probably like active  woman maybe in charge of herself taking  like running a business he's smart doing  it all I mean now that I know that he  cooks does he have any children yeah  [Music]